but even to develop your style it takes
years of stage time in hours of stage
time and through that there is a lot of
failure involved and I can only imagine
with your personality on stage just the
some of the epic bombs that have had to
have gone down
I have probably bombed harder than most
comedians that you have seen that's why
I left the hardest when the comedian's
bombing well yeah dude I mean whenever
you see your buddy bomb that's some of
the hardest laughs I've ever had in my
life is watching friends just like this
is like quicksand the audience is just
like consuming them and you're in the
back just I'm gonna fix this room and
just like completely oh it's my favorite
so good yeah it's the best yeah so what
is probably one of the most epic bombs
you've ever had man or if you've got
booed on stage or they've gotten booed
on stage I don't know something about my
personality or maybe something about my
confidence on stage I don't know it
triggers a lot of hecklers him I'm not
having a good set like I do not know why
but I've had to deal with a lot of
people just like in weird environments
it's never like really like the great
like clubs or venues like where you get
heckled it's like your random bar shows
really yes I don't want to be here like
why is this person adding to this I
don't know I mean I've just had a bunch
of sets where it's so quiet after I do
this long act out where it's just like
they don't even like you can hear like
your own breath like inhaling and
exhaling like that's the only thing you
hear in the room is
and it's this feeling of like is
laughter or are the collapse ever gonna
come and then you have to comment and
you're like alright so uh guys didn't
like that or on to this next bit I
I mean one one epic bomb really that I
always go back to is this set that I had
at the Laugh Factory years ago where it
was early on I'm I stand up I and I just
remember it so vividly as like probably
one of the worst times I've felt on
stage is uh I wasn't quite dialed in
with my physicality yet I would just be
like super [__] on stage and I wasn't
control like I would like to think of my
set now is more of a controlled chaos
like it's dialed in I know my parameters
I know my reach and everything long
story short I did this dumb act out
where I kicked a stool into the audience
and it landed on the front row it
spilled this guy's drinks all over his
iPhone all over his wallet all over his
lap and and his date
and I just like I didn't have the tools
as a comedian yet to address it properly
and really apologize I literally was
like like and like a waitress is coming
in to tell this guy off and he's like oh
you mean mad and furious I'm like so
sorry I'm so sorry and then I just go
right in the next bit right oh I didn't
know cuz I still had time left like I
wasn't lit yet and I just like searched
sweating I was like I'm so sorry so you
guys ever notice like right into the
next bit and the audience is like oh my
why do you just use not just ulle into
the crowd and just not drinks all over
the in he's going right back into
material and it's just like this
like the bomb was so huge but the fact
that I wasn't self-aware made me bomb
even harder mm-hmm and probably not
recover oh no no that's horrible how
long into your career was that it was
like probably honestly two years in two
years and it was my buddy's birthday
that I invited him and he brought a
bunch of friends my birthday dude my
friend is really funny he's been killing
it and I just dude I just crapped the
bed entirely
[Music]